For the CarShareApp, we crated four classes. There was the CarShareApp, which
used the simulation, which used cars and persons. The simulation and car
classes go together and are specific to the CarShareApp. The person is more
general and could possibly be used for other situations. These three classes
could be organized into packages. The person class might go into a more
general, com.udacity package, and the simulation and car, would go in a more
specific, carshare package. The CarShareApp, is just a main program, that we're
writing that uses these other things, so we'll keep it in the default package.
Creating packages in BlueJ is a little bit funny, so I'll show you how to do
this. From the car share project. I'm going to look up at the menu. It's at the
upper left for me, but it might be right along this bar for you. I'll go to
Edit> New Package, and then put in the package name. Com.udacity.carshare. Now
the package appears here in Bluejay. I can open it up. This is the com package.
This is the Udacity package and this is the Car-share package in the Car-share
package I want to put the car in simulation classes. So to do that i will go to
that Edit menu again and then I select Add Classroom file and then inside the
folder that contains all of the Car-share I'll select the car and add it. Now
the car shows up in the Car-share package. But I need to add the simulation
too. Edit > Add Classroom File > Simulation > Add. Now in the Udacity package I
want to add the person. Edit > Add Classroom File and this time I'll select
Person. And now its here, so this compiles but if I go back to the Car-share
package and try to compile these or find cannot find symbol class. That's
because person is no longer right beside simulation so i have to tell Java
where to look for the person class. Where do I look for the person class? In
com.udacity. Now before I ask you a question, I've got one more clean up task.
Right now there are actually two persons. There's one in com Udacity, and
there's one in Car-share seven. So, all of the classes that I copied into
different packages, I need to remove. So I'll remove car, and it's okay that
I'm permanently removing it because I copied it. And then I'll remove person
and I'll remove simulation. So like I just mentioned, right now Car isn't
compiling. What import statements would you need to add to this project to make
it compile again? Go ahead and reorganize all of the classes into the right
packages. Then to get the CarShareApp running again. To which class should I
add the import com.udacity.person? Write none if I never need to import this.
To which class should I add the import com.udacity.carshare.car? And to which
close should I add the import com.udacity.carshare.simulation? And remember
write none if you never use a particular import statement. And separate answers
with commas, if you find that there are two classes that use the same import.